>>Peggy: Different than
a traditional classroom,
PBL's gonna integrate
assessment throughout the project.
Because these projects are multi-week
projects, you need to keep on top
of students and build in
opportunities to assess
where they are and what
they're learning as you go along
>>Sheela: From the minute a teacher
introduces that learning target
for the lesson, or engages
in strategic observation,
we feel that the assessment
process is in play.
>>Liza: It's not a test at the end
of the week or the end of the unit.
You're doing a lot of small
check-ins with the students to see
where they're at and to see
that they're growing a lot.
So some examples of formative
assessments that I use
in my classroom is fist to five.
So five is, I feel really good
about this learning target,
I'm learning what I
need to in class today.
A zero is, I have nothing.
>>Sheela: You really have to know
what kids know and don't know.
That can often determine what next
steps need to be put into place
in order to support or
differentiate the learning
for the kids in their classroom.
>>Marianne: You saw
another form of assessment,
which we call a quick check,
or checking for understanding,
and that's sort of the thumbs up.
I get it, sideways,
I'm not quite sure,
or thumbs down, no, I don't get it.
That's for them to reflect,
but it's also for us
to do a check for their
understanding.
>>Peggy: It's just sharing some of
the responsibilities for assessment
with those who are most
involved with the project,
so you give students the
opportunity to assess themselves.
You give them the opportunity
to assess their teammates.
>>Sheela: We find that some of the
most important and useful feedback is
when kids can offer it to each other.
>>Peggy: So typically in a PBL unit,
the culminating event
is what all the students
and the teacher are working toward.
So usually, this involves
inviting community members,
inviting other teachers, inviting
parents, to the classroom.
Or maybe you even do
it in the evening
and you present what the
students have learned,
whether it's the final product,
something that they created,
whether it's a solution to a
problem facing the community.
So it's usually a big deal and
the teachers should take advantage
of that being a big deal, because
the students are very proud
to present what they've learned.
It really becomes an event where
students are showcasing all
that they've learned through
this big project, and their plans
for how they're going
to pursue it further.